it's one of the things that
nanotechnology has done it has forced
people to speak across domains so you
need to First be deeply trained in
something and then while you're getting
that training be reading broadly at 10
seminars outside of your exact area so
that you can begin to learn the lingo
and you will see you probably have a
term for that in your own Sciences so I
would say learn broadly study deeply
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic
Professor Jim tour it's a pleasure to
meet you in person
yes and I followed you for such a long
time you're one of my audience kind of
recommendations and and really they've
advocated so long to have you on you are
a renowned professor of nanotechnology
at Rice University been there how many
decades or years have you been 23 years
at rice and then I did 11 years at the
University of South Carolina see this is
like uh
yeah 33 34 years and uh we're at a a
very interesting Workshop We're Not
Gonna disclose locations of where we are
to protect the innocent uh but this has
been a very stimulating conference I
would say that this conference has been
dedicated to the biggest picture topics
in all of science philosophy culture Etc
and uh maybe we'll have more to say
about that at another time but I wanted
to start off uh you are a um you are a
religious scientist you are observant
religious scientist I am an observant
religious scientist I'm practicing
religious scientists sometimes I make
the distinction we've had on Christian
Scientists of people that have worked in
science who are Christians we've had
many of those who have many more
atheists a couple of agnostics including
my first guest Freeman Dyson who was
what I call a practicing agnostic I want
to start there
um as a scientist do you think it's more
economical say to approach science from
a neutral perspective not affirming an
active intelligence behind the universe
at some level whatever that means or is
it equally valid to start from a
position of maybe a theistic origin of
the universe can a good scientist be
atheist can a good scientist be agnostic
a theistic or is there a natural
starting point whatsoever for a
scientist to approach his or her
research
yeah I've never really thought about the
question so I'm shooting from the hip
but I I think it doesn't matter uh it
doesn't matter they're good scientists
that are in each camp and they're bad
scientists that are in each Camp so so a
lot depends on your training where you
trained and and your approach to science
so so you do not have to be in in my
mind I mean there's a lot of scientists
that I know that that are not very
religious at all I've never asked them
exactly what they are but they are great
scientists
and uh we've had a lot of conversations
on this particular podcast about alien
life uh in uh in particular whether
there's specific instances of of
observed signatures of spacecraft or
around America in particular around
Southern California where I live
um but but I want to ask you is the
notion that intelligent aliens has
somehow created life whatever that means
on Earth in the universe is that
something to be taken seriously as past
guest on the show Lee Cronin has as
postulated life is ubiquitous life is
uniform and perhaps alien life is the
progenitor of life on Earth is that is
that something you take seriously
well it should be taken seriously I
think that wherever we look
we've never seen life off of this planet
and if we find life nearby off that we
need to really ask did it come from this
planet you know a lot of material has
exchanged between planets certainly we
can find things on earth
that are from Mars things that are on
Mars from Earth so we always always have
to be concerned with Exchange
I don't worry about alien life serious
not serious I don't really know I don't
worry about it at all I don't concern
myself with it and it's probably because
of my faith-based side
I am a firm believer in the Bible but
every word in the Bible is absolutely
true I love the scriptures I love the
word of God God created the heavens and
the Earth
he doesn't go into great detail on how
he did that he doesn't tell us how the
molecules came together when he formed a
man named Adam and a woman named Eve we
know that she came from some part of
Adam's side but uh he doesn't give us
much details I don't even know
how much allegory is read into that
I just take it for what it is then God
created Adam and what we do find
um
and there's been writings about this in
the Christian Community is that you find
you find more alien activity
where there has been greater occult
practice and when when a prayer comes in
and the occultist is is really
dissipated the occult activity that
dissipated the alien activity seems to
go away
so how much of that is is what the Bible
would call demonic
I don't know I really don't know these
topics well but I'm I really am not
concerned about it because because I've
read the Bible
from the beginning of the book to the
end and I know I know what the end is
going to look like and so I don't worry
about that Jim you gave a really
phenomenal talk when we laid out what is
necessary maybe contingent just focusing
on the micro machine this Exquisite
structure that we call the cell you
talked about what um what are the
contingent properties of a cell that
would be necessary to
you know credibly call life and even
beyond that the different levels of
chemistry of predecessor chemistry that
would be necessary from enzymes to base
pairs and RNA etc etc what's the most
complicated and you gave a wonderful uh
uh example you asked what what do you
think the uh people have been asked in
America I believe it was
um what's the most complicated thing
that scientists have made in the lab
maybe I'm just rephrasing it in some
sense and 30 or so thought a frog had
been created in the lab by scientists uh
which was and these are college educated
yeah 80 people yeah 80 of the people
that were interviewed had some college
Level Training either from associates
degree through PhD degree yeah and and
uh one-third of the population feels
that
believes that scientists have even
created things like frogs in the lab
two-thirds believe the scientists have
created simple single-celled organisms
like bacteria like a bacterium and and
so yeah that that's what the belief is
just a quick pause to ask you for a
small favor while my thumb is occupied
with old Albert on it yours is
presumably freed up to leave a thumbs up
on this video really helps me a lot with
a good old-fashioned YouTube algorithm
thanks a lot now back to the video I
wanted to put you at ease a little bit I
gave a talk in in Italy and Florence
actually in Galileo's old home
essentially and I put up a slide back in
2015 and it postulated or demonstrated
survey from the National Science
Foundation in America that 25 of
Americans believe that the sun orbits
around the earth so everyone in the
audience was cackling stupid American I
don't know why I use like a Russian
accent but these were Italians and I put
up I and then I revealed the next slide
33 of Europeans believe in the same
thing what is the most complicated
biological chemical entity predecessor
precursor constituent contingent
structure that humans have ever made is
it vetner's uh you know kind of coding
in an existing DNA structure what's the
most complicated thing humans have ever
no I don't I I don't think Craig
venter's work on his so-called synthetic
cells I mean he took an existing cell
he took a copy to a genome from another
cell and he put it in the first cell I
mean and that I mean that's a clever
experiment no doubt it's a clever
experiment but it's certainly not the
making of life nobody's ever gotten
close to life I mean a cell is a is a
huge Factory it's a machine it's it's
just of of so much transport so much
processing and and the target of a cell
gets harder every year and that's not
because of some evolutionary process
it's because of we got some background
folks here talk but it's all right I
think they can hear us but but
um uh the process of uh the processes
that go on in a cell are getting harder
every year to think about because we
learned for example with Carolyn do spin
selectivity that this is how a cell
makes things so
cleanly we always thought that it was
the hand and glove the enzyme and that's
the way we taught chemistry for years
and now we're learning that that's just
a part of it and maybe even the minor
part the major part is that is that uh
these chiral environments these
handedness and environments are spin
valves so only the electron of a proper
spin spin up or spin down can go down
this path and because of that there's
very little back scattering and so the
processes don't evolve much heat and
that's why a cell never burns up that's
we're always wondering about this how
can all that chemistry be taking place
in a cell and the cell doesn't just
overheat and and we see this in
biological systems our brain only puts
out at 10 watts when we are full powered
thinking about a topic and and uh and
then then you you see the interactives
the non-covalent interaction not just
the covalent but the non-covalent the
alignment of molecules is critical for
information flow that is transferring
through electrostatic potentials and
near the speed of light and the number
of combinations of non-covalent
interactions that you could have if
these things were just randomly
associated in a cell is is so there's in
a single yeast cell just protein protein
interactions is 10 to the 79 billion as
an astronomer you can think that that's
a big number
yeah that's a crazy number and so that's
just protein protein in a in a simple
yeast cell that's not protein DNA that's
that's not a carbohydrate with protein
this is protein protein
and the way the cell deals with this is
it takes the information that
Arrangement and it starts to divide it
up between the two sides and then it
clamps down and the cell divides so you
get this this progenitor is just keeps
passing it it it
you get this information flow from one
to the other
and and uh we don't know how to do this
so the complexity of the cell is so hard
nobody's Come Close there's a I showed
you a whole list of things that need to
be there in the simplest cell people
would always say oh the cells are very
simple
where you take the simplest cell that
you can possibly be modeled it's been
modeled so simple that it can't make any
of the amino acids by itself it has to
have all this exogenous input the
simplest of cells has to have so many
pieces and not a single one of them has
ever been made by a human being even
with all their Advanced Techniques let
alone a prebiotically relevant synthesis
so we are so far from this that what
whatever people have made is is absolute
Child's Play compared to
to what is happening in a Cell talk
about the arguments on the uh opposing
side steel man for me the best and and
maybe most common arguments against uh
you know an intelligent designer or some
process pre you know pre-occurring to
the formation of life on Earth perhaps
by by a large amount of time what are
some of their best arguments and maybe
some are just their most common
arguments against an intelligent
designer
but you know I don't really I don't
normally speak
toward an intelligent designer because
the scientists
I don't have any proof of that directly
now now many people will come with
inferences and I understand and I'm
sympathetic to those uh so I don't
normally speak about that as far as the
the the best proof against an
intelligent designer from my world of an
organic chemistry world I don't know
that there are any good proofs against
an intelligent designer from my world
just looking at it as a synthetic
chemist because because we're so far
from even being able to think about how
molecules would come together to form
anything remotely close to life because
molecules don't move toward life
molecules have only moved toward life
when you have a biological entity an
organism pushing them toward life
propelling them toward life or a human
being trying to organize them towards
life molecules move away from this and
so so even if you consider a liposome
which is a lipid bilayer uh people have
made lipid bilayers if you if you take
if you take lipids and you put them in
water and you bring them through sheer
it's not just shaking it's through a
shearing action you can get a liposome
which is a lipid bilayer where you have
some water on the inside and then water
on the outside even those are ridiculous
those have nothing to do with the
protocell because cells aren't like that
as we heard from from our friend Tony
footerman today the the inside has to be
different from the outside or else you
don't get a proton gradient so the thing
could never work as a cell as a living
cell the thing could just never work and
and you always have the the saturated
systems on the outside the unsaturated
ones on the inside how this happens we
don't know in in biology we know how it
happens there's something called enzymes
flippase enzymes which flip these things
around so I don't know that there are
any good arguments that that could
dispel an intelligent designer but when
we hear things though you know we're out
Under the Tuscan Sun literally and and
feeling uh the warmth warming glow you
you think back to 1896 and Lord Calvin
and speculating on the origin of the Sun
and maybe the age of the Sun and using
the best inference from the available
data at that time he concluded the sun
is 20 million years old because it's a
consuming wood or charcoal or some
biological uh you know former
protobiological substance
um you know but of course that we now
that's far far inadequate we know the
age of the sun is much many orders of
magnitude greater we know the age of the
universe is greater still what uh to
what extent can you attribute some of
the outright hostility which I I view as
ad hominem and having no a place in
science towards you but couldn't some of
it come from the fact that at some level
you're saying we can't do this we can't
do this we can't do it now we may not be
able to do it now just like we couldn't
explain the solar uh Fusion back in 1896
and therefore got a whole host of
Downstream facts wrong to what extent
are you over emphasizing the man's
ability you know humankind's ability if
you like to create um plausible origin
mechanisms why is that relevant um we we
don't know so much uh and we don't even
know what we don't know to use
rumsfeld's lingo right so
um why is man the uh human beings in a
lab why are they the standard by which
we can say we are failing or inadequate
to the task of explaining originally
yeah you make a good point as as I as
I've said before in many contexts I mean
if you asked a man or a woman in the
year 1500 will we ever have space flight
I can't imagine we'd have space flight
what is space even to them and so you
know they they didn't have even have
flight within our atmosphere
uh uh or would would people be ever able
to get to the Moon I mean how can they
answer it it's so foreign to them and if
they have said
I don't know maybe in 500 years we would
be able to do it they would have been
right at that point uh uh and and
because the best you could think of is
you know somebody got up to a very high
mountain and jumped and somehow got
there so so it's it it's hard to imagine
how how um how these these things can
can can uh
we can think about this that's why I
never say we will never know I just say
it's very far from today and the more we
learn about the cell the more the the
the target the goal moves away from us
much faster than we're moving toward it
that's what tells me that we're nowhere
close I could never just operate or say
we're nowhere close I have to base that
on something and the something is that
every year we learn more about the cell
that makes it more complex and so so uh
um I I suspect that we will someday
figure out how life was formed I think
we will and that doesn't that doesn't
negate God for me I mean there's a lot
of things just because we figured out
the structure of DNA doesn't lessen God
it makes God all the greater to me it's
like oh so that's how you do it so so I
I think it makes God all the more
magnanimous in my mind I mean he doesn't
change he's static I mean he's always
been magnanimous he just is greater in
my own mind and that's what I love about
science the more I learn about science
and and and particularly about
biological systems as a chemist as I
learned about biological systems I'm
like Lord you are magnificent yeah no no
that's I made the point today you know
as as someone I I characterize myself as
a devout practicing agnostic uh in that
I am searching I am not making
stipulations that there is no God I had
a lunch conversation earlier with some
people that said you know I'm a devout
atheist essentially and I had this
conversation with with Freeman Dyson the
very first podcast on the end to the
impossible I said Freeman what are you
and he said I'm agnostic and I said oh
okay so um what church do you go to and
he said well I don't go to church I said
oh so you mean to tell me Freeman with
all love and respect as I have for him
uh I said you go you don't go to the
same church that Richard Dawkins doesn't
go to in other words How could an
intelligent alien look down at an
agnostic an agnosticism to be a great
cop-out because people aren't willing to
take a side uh it means unknowable but
it doesn't mean that you don't have
elements of practice in other words
Freeman you are functionally
indistinguishable from an atheist by
your practice you may believe in the
open to the possibility and I've had
conversations with Lawrence Krauss from
a prominent atheist militant
self-declared militant atheist do you
get the sense that your opponents ever
doubt their atheism uh because I assume
you doubt your faith on occasion I doubt
I I doubt Faith all the time but I'm
less on the you know spectrum of
religious uh observance or Fidelity
perhaps lesson you doubt your faith
first of all I shouldn't appreciate you
asking me I'm asking you Jim yeah
absolutely not you don't doubt your face
not not for a second not the Odyssey not
the children gets cancer dies at age you
know with five years old at the peak of
his or her cuteness no there's a there's
a ton that I can't understand that I
don't understand
but I love the Lord Jesus Christ with
all my heart I love him so much and uh
you know I haven't experience with the
Lord when I came to know him at the age
of 18.
and uh uh where his presence filled the
room
right there in my room I never had an
experience before that like it I never
had an experience like that
and that was so rich and I will I just
don't doubt him I just don't that's the
wrong experience yeah it it it's it's
just part of me and and uh
um no so I don't I was talking to a very
eminent lawyer uh in in California
recently and I said you know there's all
these Notions of of well this and that
is just circumstantial evidence he said
well actually circumstantial evidence in
a court of law is actually very highly
yeah you know uh reliable
um for me I do doubt and I find there is
doubt I also find there's no doubt on on
the militant atheist side they are never
questioned by the birth of a child by
the opening of a flower by the wings of
a hummingbird by the biological
Mysteries of the cell uh and that I find
that that's non-scientific
um I'm not accusing you're an eminent
scientist but to never doubt um or not
to believe that there could be a
falsification of a hypothesis again I
don't put popper on a pedestal but but
is there um is there any combination of
evidence or or or
or direct evidence other than personal
revelation that can bring one to a
specific you know instantiation of God
we have this conversation at the end of
uh the session earlier today you know is
God benevolent you know can you go from
intelligent design to uh benevolent
design could there be malevolent design
uh I find those conversations
fascinating uh because I also think they
might be unanswerable because not
everyone has had the Revelation personal
revelation that you attest to and that
you were witness to I certainly haven't
uh I should point out we're both
biologically born Jewish we both have
interesting paths to our to our practice
and our faith
um but um but I've always wondered is
there an argument uh from scientific
design that would lead to a specific
instantiation of a theology do you find
is that possible could you essentially
have the same Faith you know but from a
scientific point of view in The Virtue
and reality of Jesus Christ to you
you know this is a hard question for me
it's hard because I don't normally think
in these contexts I don't speak often to
philosophers and not that you're a
philosopher but you're speaking
philosophically and and uh so I've
really not thought much about this
um
I guess I'm a lot simpler
in my faith
and in my understanding than many other
people
ah um
you know I love the scriptures I love
the word of God it means so much to me I
love the Lord and uh um and I enjoy my
science you know I don't even I know
that God is good I know that he is kind
I know that he is gracious I know that
man is rebellious I see it in my own
heart I see how how Wayward I am how
fickle I can be I see how I at one
minute I use my tongue to praise God and
the next second I'm cursing man and I
see I see what's there so so um
if there's anything good anything
righteous anything holy I mean it's all
because of the grace of God and if
there's anything Wicked it it it it's
all because of the wickedness of man and
and so for me it's it's a much in a way
it's a simpler question and I don't even
ask it that much so it's hard for me to
answer you because I haven't really
pondered these things we'll get back to
our science in just a bit because I mean
I can't resist with such an eminent
scientist it's just talk shop and and
understand what really excites you about
nanotechnology Nano machines chemistry
of the of the cell Etc but before we
move off of the philosophical bent that
you mentioned and I should say a
physicist early word for physicist was
natural philosopher right so Galileo
spoke about natural philosophers and
derisive terms but he was a natural
philosopher I can't resist it so the one
thing that I am curious about and Isis
of Stephen Meyer when he was on this
podcast a year and a half ago for his
book a return of the god hypothesis he
said at what level does God intervene in
your in your estimation is it at the
level of uh well there's a cell
germination or a sperm and an egg or DNA
or cell or DNA or RNA or the you know
the fine structure constant or the
gravitational potential or the
inflationary perturbation Spectra at
what level and how because the key
Revelation or that I've had from talking
to militant atheists and other atheists
like Sean Carroll who calls himself a
poetic naturalist who's been on the show
is that there's no term in the standard
model lagrangian that in that is even
um has an exchange interaction with
anything that is necessary to explain
the properties of say particle physics
just restricting ourselves to something
simple like lagrangian of the standard
model where does God intervene how early
does God intervene because as I said I
think it's a problem if I tell my kids
oh that rainbow over there so beautiful
and they say Oh Daddy how did it get
there that's how God made it you know I
think that's short circuits their
ability to become good scientists
themselves not that I force them but so
what level and how can a god entity can
can see you know a theological entity or
maybe just just an intelligent designer
what element can he intervene with with
nature and how right so I I would say
that that fundamentally I am a
progressive creationist meaning that
that God didn't just set the whole thing
off and then it ran by itself that there
were specific acts of creation where he
he he set this thing in motion he called
the molecules together however he does
that through so self-assembly or
and and and gets it into this this very
very stable high energy state
as we learned about this morning uh um
and and so
I don't know the details I know what the
scriptures say
that
that
everything has been created by Him
everything
and and uh the details of this I don't
know this this is what he gives us the
ability to investigate and to to look at
and some of these things we learn you
know that that this this then then
modifies and now we have a new structure
based on this I don't understand it all
the places it could be as fundamental as
as the electrons moving around this
proton these protons in the nucleus
uh
um you know does this happen all by
itself is there something where he is
there at that level you know I don't
know I don't know enough about
about an atom to know
really really what's happening here but
there's no doubt that he's he
these things up and they seem now to run
autocatalytically they seem to run by
themselves
but I don't know what happens if he
lifts his hand from all this for an
instant if the whole thing just just
spins out of control I don't know uh
maybe as a physicist you know better you
say no these things are very controlled
there's no problem you have this Force
you have that force and these things are
well defined I take these things and I
use these to my advantage all the time
because I know exactly how these
molecules are going to respond and they
do it the same way every time and so
when I pray God bless my reactions bless
my work I'm not saying just bless it for
me
not somebody else because if it's not
reproducible then I'm in big trouble but
it it's it's more of a Lord guide me in
in the right way guide me in in the way
of truth because the Bible says that the
darkness and the light are the same to
him
so he sees
in he sees in the in the darkness and I
don't he sees things that I don't see
and have said Lord enlighten me so that
I can see this thing too you're asking
me a very deep question and I'm not sure
I'm giving you the answer that you
deserve no I think but I'm trying yeah
no I think it is and I think the earnest
approach that you have is refreshing Jim
I think there's too much um kind of
anodyne uh you know this dissociation of
the soul of a scientist because we are
human beings if not good luck to
artificial intelligence and you know
it's gone let me know the answer at the
end we are human beings Einstein said
the greatest joy he ever had was a
visualization that a person in free fall
would experience no gravitational forces
tell me how can an AI how can something
dispassionate how can they even
comprehend what Free Fall is let alone
what Joy is so I think to dissociate the
the soul from the scientist is a grave
error of our time and it's Unique to our
time Harvard was started as an
institution to teach theology Divinity
teaching he couldn't graduate without
knowing Hebrew and there's there's so
many paths we could go down here I guess
I can't resist but to ask you about your
and I have to say you asked me how does
God do it or how you ask yourself how
does God do it if he keeps sustaining it
what is it like from his perspective
dark and lighter the same is is
meaningless to us it doesn't mean it's
meaningless ultimately but it reminds me
of a joke that my uh one of my kids told
me said dad you know did you ever hear
about the story where the kid asked God
um you know God what is uh what does a
million years like to you and God says
it's like a second to you my son and
then the kid said wow God what's a
million dollars like to you and um and
God says to the boy it's like a penny to
you and the boy thanks for a second says
God can I borrow a penny
and God says yes in a second
we can't comprehend these things but to
not confront these things as most people
especially my Jewish friends like
Lawrence Cross I debated this on my
podcast with him I said Lawrence when
was the last time you uh thought
seriously about God studied the Torah
the Old Testament he's Jew uh lapse he
had Apartments which I didn't uh but I
said you know when I was bar Mrs I said
Lawrence let me ask you a question if
some kid who's 12 13 years old comes up
to you some little pishes we would say
and says Lawrence your theory of the
Universe from nothing is total you know
nonsense it's uh it's inadequate it
doesn't seem right it doesn't sound
right to me
um you would say you know what do you
know you're 13 years old and yet you
learned you are refuting and rejecting a
tradition that you last studied at age
12. see what do you know and it was
clear you know it was kind of shaking
but he couldn't yeah he'll never I'll
never convert that's not my job is to
bring him back to do Toshiba Jim I have
a little gift for you this is a fragment
of the Earth's Moon uh which was brought
here uh via gravity and eventually the
U.S Postal Service out to me it's 0.251
grams if I told you that somewhere deep
inside of this Moon meteorite which is
your gift for coming on the into the
impossible podcast if deep inside of
there and I'd love it if you look for it
in your laboratory
um there's a there's an there's DNA what
would that say to you what would that
mean to you thank you very much buddy oh
that would probably tell me that
something went from the earth to the
moon and the moon and then the moon back
and what about the reverse hypothesis I
have this debate with Sean Carroll the
non-observation of life on the Moon and
the non-observation of Life on Mars yes
we haven't searched everywhere and
evidence absence of evidence but doesn't
it not have to have some bayesium uh
prior reduction I mean doesn't it tell
us something that we haven't seen a mega
City on I mean it might not tell us very
much but it tells us something does it
not that life is ubiq or the exchange of
material from Earth to the Mars and Mars
to the Earth and the moon to the earth
etc for billions of years does that not
give us something to say about the
efficiency of so-called panspermic
origin of life oh yeah on Earth sure I
I'm fine I'm fine with with Life coming
from somewhere else what I'm talking
about is origin of first life yes and so
even if some some Advanced preachers
came and seated it here and it took off
I mean I I'd say Okay where'd those
creatures come from and that's what I'm
I'm dealing with this is very nice of
you thank you so so this is this is
lunar regolith okay not brought by the
astronauts brought by uh eBay
so uh we have a new session starting in
a little bit uh I want to ask you first
of all
um what's the most exciting
um aspect of your research what Jazz you
up every day to do the work that you do
as a distinguished professor at Rice
University what what is that to you I
have four children you might as well ask
me which one do I love the most I mean
it's the top 10 things it's whatever
whatever is in front of me at that
moment I mean this we're using Flash
flash fuel heating to make graphene from
trash this is really interesting we take
Municipal trash boom and no solvents no
water Boom the whole thing turns into
graphene that you can put into concrete
and building material and wow and uh and
then we're using it to to volatilize
Metals out of out of electronic waste
which is the fastest growing waste in
the world we're using it to remediate
soil so this is a very exciting thing
our little Nano machines that are
drilling into cells to kill them killing
super bacteria killing MRSA and all
these these deadly bacteria that are
killing hundreds of thousands of people
every year so this is this is really
exciting to me to be able to to work on
projects like this and uh um uh so we we
we walk work from medicine to materials
to to to interesting ways of of
synthesis and uh um I love it all I'm
like a kid in a candy store we have a
lot of young listeners uh that are that
are maybe considering graduate school
maybe beginning graduate school um what
advice do you have for a student who's
fascinated by these these Nano machines
is this technology that you are
pioneering and I've done such an eminent
work and what advice do you give to such
a young student well you know they say
the the people that that have the
biggest effect
uh Across The Sciences are people that
are T people like the letter t
the people that are highly trained in
some discipline that's why I don't think
you should get a degree in something as
nebulous as nanotechnology it's too
broad you need something in chemistry or
physics or biology something that goes
very deep and then be able to speak
across many different disciplines be
able to to cover many disciplines so
that you're reading broadly so you know
I have a company that makes electronic
memory I've company it's companies that
that work on these Nano machines others
they're straight drug companies others
that are straight materials companies
and I've learned to speak across many
domains and that's one of the things
that nanotechnology has done it has
forced people to speak across domains so
you need to First be deeply trained in
something and then while you're getting
that training be reading broadly at 10
seminars outside of your exact area so
that you can begin to learn the lingo
and you will see you probably have a
term for that in your own Sciences so
for example when I start started working
with physicists I mean they would talk
about a polar on it and what is a
polaron it's a polarized but we have a
term in chemistry called radical cation
I know I know what a radical cation is
and and we're talking about the same
thing it's just the different
terminology and the way they view things
I talk about electrostatic potential
physicists talks about a virtual Photon
I'm like that's a virtue I know what a
photon is what's a virtual Photon well
this is this is the same thing where I
have an electrostatic potential I start
pushing two electrons together they want
to repel and and so they they it's
terminology and they view things a
little bit differently than we do and I
learn from that so so I would say learn
broadly study deeply
in the remaining couple of minutes I
usually ask three existential four
existential questions we only have time
for one
um this one has to do with what uh
Richard Feynman called the cataclysm
question I should point out of course
the Richard feynman's famous for an
essay called there's plenty of room at
the bottom which is one of the
pioneering uh aspects of nanotechnology
from the 50s or 60s he said that um what
if if the uh Earth is faced with the
cataclysm in Armageddon of sorts and we
want to encode or encrypt the most
information in the smallest amount of
sentences to describe it such that and
this is my take now we can put it on a
time capsule and send it off into space
to give a little brag a little Swagger
about what human beings of Glory of the
human creation
um what would that be for you he said
the atomic hypothesis you can't say that
what would encapsulate the most
information that human beings in their
greatest Glory could brag about with a
little bit of swagger uh for all
eternity in your estimation I I would
say the scriptures
you take that and you set it up because
that's that's what certainly humanity is
going to need if it's ever going to
start over again
okay Jim tour uh the same professor of
uh nanotechnology of chemistry at Rice
University
um it's such a pleasure I do want to do
a part too we only barely scratch the
surface maybe our time here or uh by
zoom in the near future Jim this is a
pleasure thank you thank you Jim
[Music]
[Music]